welcome to this video playing a lucky
guy Grandmaster lucky guy who was this
person no take-backs ok I would account
from 2004 Vietnam okay i'm gerry I like
c5 but I have mostly forgotten how it is
played really okay now probably not risk
this COK play with H form that's an
interesting interesting variation uh-huh
bishop this early Bishop d3 yet
surprising what normally does not
exchange this so early okay
yeah you would think that the trade of
the light squared bishops so early on
should help black in some way can i play
see 5 or is this questionable he might
have see form to open up the position
quickly maybe I can first improve my
development a bit like put this here
it's not a bad place for the night
anyway the question is is he going for
maybe is going for be 3z form this is
this kind of idea c5 I'm always afraid
of c-4 may be wrong this we can't play
Queen a 6 this is a good idea probably
trying to exchange Queens yeah and now
after i think i want to capture after
this at least he cannot play he couldn't
play this how we know i can give them
sugar okay i did sits it's a pawn
briefly I was thinking okay 96 he can
take a6 and damaged my pawn structure
yeah and he can but it's not it's not a
big issue um okay going to put the
knight on d5 the Alice's certainly the
way or the place of where I want to be
with my my night
yeah we're taking us probably a bad idea
just just put it on d5 our queen is a
bit a bit of sight yeah it does have
absolutely no square to go to 94 to the
6th that sets this idea and something
like be 696 is blundering the Queen
right away definitely definitely true
now if you like a naughty fall artistic
is not it's not a fatal fatal thing to
happen but I don't really know how to
how to get the Queen back into the game
look like f6 is probably far to lose
night before is also an idea by the way
night before me
I have six looks very loose but it gets
it gets maybe a rock on them I can't do
that I look on the D foul rookie one is
a move why this can be very dangerous Oh
rookie one threatening Queen f5 eyes
looks fishy I shouldn't have done that I
f6 was terrible probably very very bad
even Luke takes e6 as it possible that
you know my queen is on a six oh this is
terrible ff6 was I was way off them hmm
why Jack
no I have six plus oh what a bad move
hmm so any way to save this probably not
after Quinn Texan I was 95 that's all
very easy to play and playing without my
queen IAM ah terrible i don't think i
was a boss so bad but I don't play of
six nothing terribly bad happening I
think maybe I'm wrong I don't know but
check this definitely made it very easy
for me f 60 check check check
check
it's not the big problem is here he has
not even sacrificed anything for this
can easily continue the attack with with
some move not sure at the moment what he
should do it's only pretty clear that i
should be toast if he finds the right
stuff check it's not founded yet but
there must be something I guess not
seeing it though maybe the stuff is
somehow somehow not lost immediately
okay this is a stripe tries to take here
at night h6 night age six is really just
a check at the moment I night age six
rupee aid maybe I should have thought
for a moment it's not not mmm night age
six just wins now adds very trivial why
doesn't he play that night age 60 k from
find morally frustrating this was a very
easy win fam maybe this also wins but
not not s.o.s quick age six there any
any defense h6 Queen f8 maybe maybe
h6 queen of eight is easy to see but I
don't have a move ready night h6 earlier
was a very simple winner even made
night hangs but okay
still still this game is continuing
it's probably still winning for white i
meanyes really refuses to to kill me for
some reason but check check Jim what is
this couple of points down jack try and
check try and some some counter check
here rook h8 mate check come on check oh
come on brah oh oh [ __ ] me raw him
before we know Tasha offered gras I
would have one on time and he completely
beat me up yeah people might think I
should have one on time or whatever but
wow I mean I always was was just a
checkmate I have four f6a I mean this is
so bad this move really really really
yeah okay so what should I do now maybe
just not be form I this this cannot be
so terrible for black really i have this
nice Knights d5 and f5 and computers has
equal with night before this kind of
thing you see it doesn't do it I thought
you might go here I still so just
shuffling yeah okay because here once
the queen is off d3 I really have this
idea b6 and getting the Queen back okay
yeah okay this is probably okay from him
I understand here I really think I
should be ok as I have this this nice
block here d5 f5 f6 wow what a move yeah
heads it so totally unplayable and maybe
here I should have at least castled long
it's still lost but that's a shank a
disaster yeah 95 as a maid check aim
Bishop r6s mate check get this
definitely also wins check or song check
let's see if what he did win snide have
Sam now it's still wins plus 5 yeah
probably there's something more
convincing even but this is like a total
win Quincy aid I would I wondered if I
had have done that this was the easiest
spot and I cannot go here because of
check this made check checkmate so I
after night h6 I definitely ups here
come on I have to take this and put he
just he just witnessed the exchange and
continues to attack with even two extra
points here this this yeah let's say
here check and then he's just picking up
pieces f6 world the disaster and of
course lots of things are winning here I
could have played queen of age when yeah
I thought about this briefly but okay I
have 40 seconds and he completely beat
me to shreds Queen f7 s not that clear
okay then whatever it was just the total
a total loss check check okay I could I
could also resign him check
and I felt like you can can try for for
some cheap tricks at least with check
check at the end we we made this job
where he was losing one time and and I'm
I'm on position okay while f6 was
terrible thanks for watching